mais si edouard limonov qui regrette que
gorbatchev laisse tomber les
kalachnikovs ilan au spleen de staline
quand le néo stahl des balles c'est
infernal
alors edouard limonov tu as dit j'ai
toujours pensé que pour injecter 20 le
look était capital et apparemment tu le
mets en pratique t es propos tu penses
ouais t'as mis en quoi la scène uniforme
d'une soldat rouge ouais avec les
épaulettes des colonels rouge des
colonels d'artillerie avec les bottes
ils ont dû totalitaire pour écraser les
démocraties avec les les étoiles tout ça
et c'est cet uniforme c'est les mêmes
uniformes qui est pris berline vienne
prague
oui et tout ça est à auschwitz aussi
mais alors on est carrément dans le
coeur du sujet puisque tu fais un point
qui s'appelle la grande époque chez
flammarion et qui parle effectivement de
du trend après la grande guerre
tu parles de ton père qui était
capitaine non dans l'armée rouge oui mon
père était comme j'étais née elle était
soldat tous les deux venus les kenyans
capitaine après les staline lanouaille à
staline danois ya école militaire
drago l'agm à l école militaire les
sorties car depuis officiers des jours
toi c'est une grande époque ça parce que
la pire époque du celi comme ma famille
était très simple mon grand père était
né un village monde autres grandes
persie était né anglaise pour nous c'est
de grande époque parce que mon père qui
était déjà né dans une petite ville il
est l'impossibilité d'aller à l'école
militaire de devenir officier peut-être
ans pour des enfants d
des d'élèves vie aux bolchéviques c'est
mauvais pour nous c'était grande époque
vraiment vraiment est aussi c'était
l'époque de l'homme en uniforme des
longues forte je le faire oui je
cherchais justement pour montreux man 2
niveaux vrai héros tu sais je n'ai pas
trouver parmi les migrants temporaires
je regardais dans les 1947 et je vois
mon père dans l'est dans les uniformes
des parades
c'était formidable c'est toujours sera
toujours une image des vrais hommes
pour vous y tempèrent ils travaillent et
paul nkvd il est oui évidemment il est
travaillé pour une comédie après pour
ministère des affaires intérieures
oui ils étaient tous à vie au 28 ans
quoi qu'il en voyait des gens dans des
goulags
mais les officiers ne doit pas laisser
les juges qu'il envoie les gens
ordinaires mais s'il est si les
quelqu'un qui travaille au ministère de
l'intérieur en france il envoie les gens
à boulaq je ne suis pas sûr mon père
était lui balance d'une sorte de nos
officiers des gendarmeries que c'est
c'est ça les définitions des crs disons
officiers des crs ont été fascinés par
l'armée rouge pour ça c'est dit donc un
en même temps
et habillée comme ça q regrette ce qui
s'est passé en afghanistan a perdu la
vie au jeune actrice
non mais c'est pas vrai et puis
finalement on n'est pas participé dans
les batailles c'est sur la personne n'y
a en plus été bonne gamundi bon chambre
des pour un enterrement un intérêt
commun pour attirer non non c'est pas ça
j'ai oublié le nom mais pour pour s'est
entraîné à entraîner ah oui c'est ça
c'est toujours bien d'avoir les
officiers des cadres d'y aussi par les
guerres c'est toujours nécessaire pour
les chacals et je sais vu que les france
de la même chose en tchad
bien sûr servi bien sûr c'est une blague
quand même et il te situer qu'est ce que
tu préfères dans kapitalis par exemple
je vais te dire je suis plus efficace
mois le soul et capitalise l'étude je
déteste dans le capitalisme qu'est ce
que je déteste l'hypocrisie et dans le
communisme ce que tu préfères communisme
c'est une collectivisme aussi je préfère
le communisme ce collectivisme que les
gens sont plus ou moins égales ils sont
pas égales mais beaucoup plus égale
qu'ici ça disons oui parce que c'est une
sorte on égalité
sais tu sais les communismes prix des
trois slogan des révolutions france l
égalité fraternité elle il a fait
vraiment il est ici les faits beaucoup
d' égalité et fraternité liberté donc
j'allais te demander si tu animes ckpa
de liberté donc s'effectuer non mais c
'est encore c'est une réalisation dix
ans comme 3 fraternité égalité aussi et
généralisation de liberté aussi cette
liberté de faire quoi
une sorte d'aidé tu sais c'est quand
même je pense que les mots démocratie
liberté totalitarisme ses soucis c'est
le mode et vocabulaire de la guerre
froide
maintenant ils sont pas utilisables ce
que tu peux pas d'y finir c'est quoi
liberté liberté défaire poids liberté
personnelle liberté décès manifestaient
liberté vraie liberté en est besoin
une personne sur mais lyon n'est besoin
de liberté totale
est ce que tu crois que les gens de rda
qui passe aujourd'hui en rfa est ce que
tu crois qu'ils vont perdre leur
religion capitalisme aussi après trois
quatre supermarchés comme ça où sont les
dépenses et leurs samba est ce que tu
crois qu'ils vont perdre leur union
à chacun ses illusions c'est à dire les
différentes classes sociales pour dix
ans pour les langues des cultures pour
les intellectuels ces libertés des
pareilles c'est plus importante qu'elle
et les affaires dans une liberté
d'acheter les choses mais je crois oui
oui toi tu as perdu tout les gens sur la
ce a perdu toutes les illusions sur la
pérestroïka tu dis que ça fait partie
chez les russes du d'un repenti sme de
ce pays est tien qui est comme ça de se
laisser subjuguer par un occident
effectivement comme tu le disais vieux
et sans orgueil sensibilité justement
qu'est corrompu kaki et déliquescent
tu penses que quand la pérestroïka
cellule du ressenti j'ai salué
les stocks dans les deux mains
des dizaines démocratisation des gosses
le 10 mai mais il ne faut pas détruire
les passer c'est une paris est ce que tu
penses que la russie va évoluer dans la
social démocratie ou vernis sionisme et
non non je crois pas je crois que ce
sera ce soir le tout ça encore du pays
communiste
pas question c'est à dire pis que
collectiviste qui pensent que ça va
continuer comme ça oui pourquoi
pourquoi il faut déchirer et où il faut
casser toutes les structures des
sociétés qui est déjà établie c'est
toujours très pénible nez cassé sais-tu
regrette un peu que quoi qu'il arrive à
cessenon et je regrette oui je regrette
la grande époque à l'image du pays et
lui demande
je regrette quoi je regrette cette
l'homme c'est l'image de l'homme qui
était peut-être pendant les guerres
surtout tu saignes l'image de l'homme
qui bat qui est le soldat garrett des
corrections de ne rien rater de finale
andy tu es abonné vous mettez un pouce
bleus